on rejoint ce soir je n'ai pas la pierre
qui le maire des îles-de-la-madeleine de
deuxième vice président de la fédération
québécoise des municipalités et porte
parole en matière de transport aérien à
la fédération bonsoir monsieur lapierre
reçoit monsieur fillion d'abord comment
vous accueillez la reprise des vols
régionaux qui est annoncé dans l'entente
d'hier avec air canada
en fait l'ensemble de la nouvelle est
accueillie de deux façons très
différentes
d'abord avec soulagement et un soutien
de presque 6 milliards comme vous l'avez
bien expliquer un dos tres de je veux
qu'ils aient offert air canada et ça à
la fédération québécoise des
municipalités
on le dit depuis le début son sauveur
canada ce transporteur national et on se
doit d'être en mesure de transporter à
l'échelle du pays aux états unis et même
à l'international
maintenant pour ce qui est du volet
régional ou interrégional comme on peut
le vivre au québec mais nous sommes
extrêmement déçus parce qu'à première
vue on semble être oubliée de cette
entente là où même temps c'est de cet
angle à la fois par le fédéral mêmes ou
si par air canada puisque l'entente
stipule que arcana deux doigts trouve
fabuleux longtemps ou réaliser une
entente avec des sous contractants avec
une autre entreprise aérienne qui n'est
pas au jazz qui desservaient nos régions
auparavant donc arts canada ne fait même
pas compte le nouveau l'opportunité de
faire des affaires en région avec sa
propre filiale mais accepte d'être
obligé de sous traiter à un autre
transporteur qu'on ne connaît pas en
date d'aujourd'hui on ne connaît pas les
ramifications ne connaît pas la vision
se transporter là et on ne connaît pas à
tout le moins que de quelle façon il
compte desservir les régions et surtout
quel modèle est ce que nous ce qu'on
veut et jour de la marmotte
oui clairement est ce que ça pourrait
être parce quand est ce que ça pourrait
être des entreprises qui vole déjà vers
les régions en fait ces notes soit il ya
des transporteurs québécois qui ont à
bout de bord et des cervidés région pour
des services essentiels depuis le début
de la pandémie au québec on peut penser
à pascal via sion on peut penser à erie
noël a incrit beck qui sont des
compagnies détenues par des intérêts
québécois qui sont supportés par des
communautés à travers
le québec et qui malgré tout malgré les
difficultés liées au transport aérien
durant la pandémie depuis un peu plus
d'un an ont maintenu un niveau de
service minimum dans l'ensemble des
régions du québec pour soi bien entendu
supporté par un programme québécois
qu'on appelle le pam serré puce en fait
qui est un financement offert à la fois
par le fédéral et le provincial
mais ces transporteurs laon menu des
services aériens qui ont rendu de fiers
services boya aux régions au québec
donc on souhaite fédéral travaille avec
ces entreprises et donc qui est que
c'est que ces entreprises là deviennent
les sous traitants d'air canada mais
c'est quoi votre inquiétude que cette
que cette entente ne se fasse pas ou que
ça se fasse aux conditions d'air canada
en fait ce qu'on souhaite pas c'est que
ce soit un jazz 4.0 que ce soit le
retour de retour d'air canada dans nos
régions avec le même modèle qu'on a
connu auparavant et le modèle des arts
canada qu'on a connus avant la pandémie
écrasé la concurrence réalisait des
guerres de prix déloyal pour tracer la
concurrence des régions pour tomber en
situation presque monopoliste est quasi
monopolistique dans la plupart des
régions du québec
et l'on connaissait des hausses de prix
faramineuses écoutez on a souvent connu
des billets d'avion au coût de 20 $
aller-retour des îles montréal valdes à
montréal 8 900 $ ou moins la même chose
c'était la même chose
gaspé la même chose alors qu'on peut
très bien partir des îles de la
madeleine avec air canada allé
auparavant avant la pandémie aller à
cuba pour une semaine pour 1500 $ alors
évidemment ce territoire à la case
départ pour vous exactement ce qui est
présenté sous la forme qu'il est
présentée lors c'est un retour à la case
départ
est ce parce qu'on pressent le
gouvernement fédéral d'annoncer des
investissements la création d'un fonds
conjointement avec le gouvernement
provincial pour soutenir la relance du
transport aérien dans les régions avec
des transporteurs québécois les
transporteurs régionaux qui existe déjà
dans les perspectives de d'assurer une
pérennité du service autant pour la
mobilité des personnes que pour la
mobilité des marchandises et des biens
puisque on oublie souvent qu'un marché
ne qui sous-exploité a développé il ya
des marchandises qui seront transportés
dans les avions
dans le ciel québécois et ça je pense
que ça amène des perspectives de
développement et travailler des
entreprises comme pascal via sion un
québec où air et nous et nous amène à
ses perspectives le qui sont
intéressants et le projet de coopérative
très qui doit prendre son envol bientôt
des allers-retours d'ailleurs sont
prévus aux îles il y aura une classe
pour ça selon vous
et puis encore une fois il faut un
leadership du gouvernement provincial et
aussi du fédéral dans ce dossier là
actuellement le transport aérien c'est
en dents de scie on passe de presque
zéro transporteurs qui desservent nos
régions à terme si on se fie aux
annonces qui sont faits à plusieurs
transporteurs
bon il ya les trois qu'on connaît qui
existe déjà la coopérative trek et en
développement actuellement qui annoncent
une ouverture une mise en service à
partir de demain et la semaine dernière
il y avait par porter airlines qui
annonce reprendre en fait l'ensemble des
destinations délaissé par air canada
donc c'est un peu tout le monde cherche
à se trouver une place
mais il n'y a pas la place pour tous les
joueurs dont ils font qu' un leadership
politique fort pour assumer par le parti
de gouvernement
ok le message est lancé un mot quelques
secondes monsieur la pierre sur la butte
atlantique qui revient selon ce qu'on
apprend ce soir le 3 mai prochain ça
veut dire quoi pour les îles de la
madeleine ça en fait c'est encore
complications bon écoutez depuis plus
d'un an un ici on doit demander la
permission au nouveau-brunswick et à
l'île-du-prince-édouard pour sortait de
chez nous et pour revenir chez nous on
fera du québec donc on est obligé de
demander aux provinces atlantiques la
permission et ça c'est très décevant
quoique prévisible avec la flambée des
cas au québec et ce qui s'est passé dans
les provinces atlantiques
on sort et la situation de près on en
contact avec notre gouvernement le
gouvernement du québec pour intervenez
auprès des provinces atlantiques pour
trouver une façon d'assurer une fluidité
des déplacements des passagers là en
danses des îles ou à destination des
îles à madeleine avec la saison
touristique qui arrive encore bientôt
vous attendez des touristes cet été mais
sur la pierre oui absolument
en fait on nous annonce jusqu'à tout
récemment une très belle saison
touristique des voyants étaient au vert
savoie ont à nouveau on avait le qui
dessert la communauté des îles à portée
de souris à l'île du prince édouard bien
entendu depuis la semaine dernière
depuis que les déplacements sont
interdits d'une région d'une région
rouge une région aux jambes comme
l'annoncent à soulever certaines
inquiétudes
on garde encore espoir je pense que la
saison il ya encore du temps avant le
début de la saison on est encore en
avril la saison va plus débuter vers la
fin mai début juin
alors on a bon espoir que la situation
va se résorber au québec et que les gens
vont pouvoir venir aux
îles-de-la-madeleine nos visites
espérons le
sur la pierre merci beaucoup mais c'est
à vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit